qu'est-ce-qui pourquoi en ce moment avec
le système le mode de scrutin actuel est
ce que tu veux que je commençais à dans
le fameux tic ou par catégorie la
situation actuelle n'est peut-être pas
parfaite mais elle allume béret bleu
clair le gouvernement a déposé un projet
de loi pour modifier le mode de scrutin
sur 125 députés 87 élus dans des
circonscriptions comme c'est le cas
actuellement et 45 seraient choisis sur
des listes en proportion du vote reçues
par chaque partie dans chaque région il
y aurait donc moins de circonscription
ce qui veut dire qu'elle serait
forcément plus grands
a priori la réforme du mode de scrutin
je pense que vous étiez plutôt favorable
oui michel adrien a été maire de
mont-laurier pendant 15 ans il a
constaté les limites du système actuel
le mode électoral donner quelques fois
des résultats qui était à tout le moins
surprenant mais il a maintenant des
doutes sur la réforme proposée la
circonscription de labelle où se trouve
mont-laurier fait déjà dix huit mille
kilomètres carrés
parce que le fait d'agrandir le thé et
droit du député provincial
ça va engendrer assurément une charge de
travail qui va être substantiellement
l'autre il s'interroge sur le partage
des responsabilités entre les députés de
circonscription et les députés de région
l'oci delà de la route 117
bon c'est un dossier qui a une
importance cruciale pour notre région
est-ce que dorénavant c'est le député
régional qui va devoir s'occuper de sept
dossiers qui couvre le territoire
régional et le citoyen ordinaire
lui aussi va falloir à quelle porte
frapper
il reste que la région des laurentides
illustre parfaitement les limites du
mode de scrutin actuel lors des
dernières élections la caq a remporté
toutes les circonscriptions avec
seulement 45 % des voix donc 45% depuis
mai 100 % des sièges du point de vue
d'un prof de maths
qu'est-ce qui va pas être le mode de ce
qui en fait le mode de scrutin ce moment
c'est que la représentation au niveau
des sièges n'est pas la même que la
représentation au niveau du vote au
dessus suffrages simon boudreault est
enseignant au centre collégial de mont
tremblant
pour lui le mode de scrutin actuel est
carrément dépassé on a deux exemples
sont assez représentatif donc 1867
pluvieux avec le plus récent qu'est ce
qu'on voit en gros en fait qu'est ce
qu'on s'en rend compte avec le plus
vieux ou ce que le parti conservateur du
québec avait gagné avec 53 perd 2 5% des
voix et les talus ramos est aussi une
majorité de sièges fait qu'on se rende
compte que c'était une double majorité
par contre qu'est ce qu'on se rend
compte en quatre en 2018 c'est que le
gouvernement de la cac a gagné avec 60 %
des sièges mais uniquement de 37% des
voix ce qui est erroné que c'est que les
37 le regard 4 % du vote représente
exactement le même nombre de votes qui
avait dans l'opposition à 1867 fait
qu'aujourd'hui avec le même nombre de
votes
on peut être gouvernement majoritaire
alors qu'avant c'était juste bon pour
l'opposition
exactement la réforme du mode de scrutin
ça fait des décennies qu'on en parle et
unique comité d'experts des
consultations citoyennes des rapports
mais rien qui ait jamais vraiment petit
donc vous monsieur champeau doute qu'ils
nous avaient déjà été menace un peu la
réforme électorale ce qu'ils appelaient
les états généraux sur la réforme des
institutions démocratiques prises des
pâtures bella et non pas de 2003
donc je passerai pour que ça prendrait
autant d'années vingtaine d'années pour
arriver à voir au moins un projet de loi
denis charbonneau était pour une réforme
du mode de scrutin à l'époque mais le
projet du gouvernement de l'entousiasme
port il craint que les gouvernements
minoritaires se multiplient et nuisait
l'exercice du pouvoir
35 un affaiblissement du poids du
pouvoir du poids francophone j'aimerais
savoir je pense à ça aujourd'hui
j'aimerais voir ce qu'ils avaient été
l'assemblée nationale au mode ou 1970 au
moment de l'adoption de la loi 101 est
ce que le est ce que le gros match
québec arrêté en mesure d'assurer notre
survivance linguistique on peut pas
comparer ce qui s'est fait dans le passé
avec des outils qu'ils étaient prêts
existants catherine droit un travail
auprès des jeunes dans le secteur
communautaire à rivière rouge
elle ne voit pas d'un mauvais oeil
l'élection de gouvernement minoritaire
et pense au contraire que les parties
devraient apprendre à mieux collaborer
oui certains détracteurs vont venir avec
des arguments tels que ouais mon
n'aurait pas fait la révolution
tranquille avec des gouvernements
minoritaires de coalition peut-être
qu'on aurait profession le fait qu'on
n'aurait pas eu besoin de se rendre
aussi à ce type de révolution là elle
pense que le mode de scrutin actuel
encourage le cynisme ça ramène les votes
stratégie qui finalement ne plaît à
personne pour dire moi je vais voter
pour inter mais je le sais que ça va
aller nulle part alors là puisque je
veux pas qu'un tel seront au pouvoir
aller voter pour un autre que je veux
pas qu'il est au pouvoir
mais sa dette comme une espèce de
sentiment d'échec en partant
confrontée à une population divisée le
gouvernement choisi de soumettre la
question à un référendum
je suis d'un naturel optimiste et je
crois que les gens tout à fait les
utiles pour pour finalement s'approprier
le concept
disons qu'il va falloir beaucoup de
pédagogie le citoyen ordinaire
il ne se livrait pas la nuit pour penser
que le point de ce coupé est inadéquat
il aurait fait en allant en pensez quoi
le référendum moi je pense que c'était
essentiel
j'espère que ça se fera de la façon la
moins partisane parce évident que si on
va au thunder cours d'eau ça avantage ou
désavantage peu de formations policiers
si le projet de loi est adopté le
gouvernement à trois ans bien expliquer
sa réforme le choix des électeurs sera
déterminant puisqu'il influencera le
point fort à leur propre vote pour les
élections à venir
[Musique]